there are days in every child's life
that
change who they are forever becoming you
is about the developmental steps kids go
through between birth and 2000 days
going from this helpless newborn to the
most sophisticated animal on the planet
and we wanted to capture that journey we
had to go and get
the best teams from around the world to
bring this level of beauty on screen
it's an extraordinarily difficult show
to make we filmed over 100 children
in 11 countries 250 days globally
we're shooting this in large format
which is new in the documentary sphere
visually it's pretty breathtaking well
technically quite a challenge when
shooting multi locations
underwater elements going across all
four corners of the globe
but also working with children it's
immensely complicated yeah
ready roll camera there's a lot of times
kids
don't want to do the behavior you're
trying to capture
like naps are my enemy
that's the real challenge you can plan
for it and hope it's going to go like
this but on the day
it's life we're not making this up we're
just here to film it can we keep
our dreams alive this is
one of the biggest things you can
possibly do in documentary filmmaking
the team really did an incredible job
you're like oh my goodness it's totally
worth it it really shows that
we're all going on the same amazing
journey i think it's really remarkable
[Music]
this is the extraordinary story all
about
[Music]
us
you